minutos antes de que william ruto fuera
declarado próximo presidente de kenia y
justo cuando una multitud comenzó a
cantar estallaron escenas de caos en la
sala de recuento los partidarios del
candidato raila odinga se abrieron paso
hacia el escenario antes de que los
soldados los obligarán a salir de la
sala junto con los diplomáticos y los
observadores los enfrentamientos
estallaron después de que cuatro altos
funcionarios electorales repudiarán el
resultado muy anoche
no podemos hacernos cargo de los
resultados que se van a anunciar debido
a la opacidad con la que se han manejado
which distrital shopping and gold
fue una carrera reñida entre ruth o un
millonario empresario y odinga ex primer
ministro que ya se había presentado a
las elecciones presidenciales en cuatro
ocasiones en su discurso de victoria
ruto prometió no mirar atrás y elogió a
la comisión electoral
el pueblo de quien ya ha ganado porque
hemos elevado la vara política el héroe
de estas elecciones es la comisión
electoral independiente y pizzi
en el bastión de odinga aquí sumo en el
este de kenia estallaron violentas
protestas con partidarios que denuncian
fraude en la comisión electoral
para crear el sistema y no quieren dar
transparencia
por eso digo que no hay paz en absoluto
desde 2002 todos los resultados de
elecciones presidenciales de kenia han
sido impugnados odinga tiene siete días
para presentar cualquier reclamo contra
los resultados mientras que el tribunal
supremo tendrá 14 días para pronunciarse